the others I Stevens from the north that
spread death darkness and cold wherever
they go by taking a look at aerosol adji
in conjunction with George RR Martin's
quote on the appearance of the others I
came to the conclusion that the others
could very well be descended from the
children of the forest and the remaining
children of the forest in blood Ravens
cave could have been persuaded to their
side in this video I'll expand upon
these ideas
very little is known about the strange
beings called the others and they've
been the topic of much discussion online
while arguably less thought is put into
the seemingly benign children of the
forest
however we almost know as little about
them as we know of the others when you
look at the histories it's easy to feel
sorry for the children of the forest
their lands were wrongfully taken
because of the greed of men and their
desire to conquer well not really it was
actually the children who attacked first
as the first men settled in Westeros
they began chopping down weirwood trees
this angered the children in the attack
which led to hundreds of years of war
the children of the forest appeared to
be the aggressors in this instance they
fought for generations until they
finally gave up and made a pact if you
look closely at the world of Ice and
Fire there's a subtle hint there the
wisest of both races prevailed and the
chief heroes and rulers of both sides
met upon the Isle in the gods eye to
form the pact the wisest of both races
prevailed what does that mean when it
comes to mankind some people are smarter
than others you're not going to find two
people that agree on everything when it
comes to men there are as many opinions
as there are people because we are
individuals
therefore distinctions such as wisest
can be made but if the children of the
forest are hive minded like some
theorists claim how can such a
distinction exist there is no wisest
Borg there is just a Borg the children
of the forest are not hive minded in my
opinion however they can store their
collective memories within the roots of
the weirwood trees so that future
generations can see and what would
future generations of the children see
they would see an incredibly one-sided
pack being made they would see their
ancestors being forced to give up all of
Westeros except for the deepest woods
but also it doesn't seem as though the
children of the forest let the first men
in on this bit of information the
children refer to the wear woods as
their gods but the only beings we know
that can see through the wear woods are
green seers like bran and bloodraven and
perhaps the children
but they are not gods I think we should
consider the fact that there are
actually no gods in those trees and if
this is true then is it not strange that
every major northern house has a
godswood with a carve the weirwood at
its center the first men brought gods of
their own when they came to Westeros it
strangely adopted the gods of the
children of the forest and completely
abandoned their old religion was that
part of the pact interesting we won't
trouble you anymore just keep one of
these trees in every major castle and
adopt our gods that's all we ask the
children had realized there was nothing
that they could do to defeat the first
men so perhaps it was a bit of deception
on their part sure they'd lose most of
the land but they're patient people and
they have 2,000 years to watch to watch
everything that men did throughout the
Age of Heroes while they were forced to
reside in a fraction of what was once
theirs and all they saw through the
trees would remain in the roots of the
where woods forever so you have to
realise just how much power this gives
them over men knowledge is power
this is cliche I know but it's true
after 2,000 years of watching the
children could easily learn the
weaknesses of men not saying they want
to I mean the children would definitely
be spying but perhaps out of perfectly
innocent curiosity when the others
finally do show up ending the Age of
Heroes the children are seemingly
nowhere to be found but when they are
found they do agree to help and together
the children of the forest and the first
men defeat the others at least that's
how the story goes hold on where the
hell were the children of the forest
before that you mean to tell me they
waited until humanity was at its most
desperate and then agreed to help
something is strange here also what's up
with the gigantic ice wall it said that
the others can manipulate ice and ways
in which men could not even
freehand how does a giant wall made of
ice stop it
I'm beginning to question the motives of
the children they obviously had the
means or at least the knowledge to
defeat the others none of the forces of
men could stay the advance of the White
Walkers they swept over all of Westeros
what could the children have done that
shifted the balance so dramatically and
why didn't they make an effort to
contact mankind but perhaps the most
intriguing question if the children knew
the threat of the others was so great
that they helped mankind build a giant
ice wall to keep them out then why do
they now appear to be on the wrong side
of it oh yeah because the Andals drove
them out of the deep wood the Andals
slaughtered the children brutally the
first men tried to help the children but
unsuccessfully after the Andal invasion
the children were nearly eradicated but
not eradicated we know that some
survived with no home they lost
everything two men not the Andals not
the first men but simply men the first
men were pushed north by the Andals but
they were far from eradicated the north
is huge that's more than enough land for
them the children of the forest were
left with nothing nothing but the
memories in the weirwood trees and
perhaps somewhat of a bitterness for
mankind I think it's more than
reasonable to consider the idea that the
remaining children of the forest are in
league with the others the children
certainly have a reason to want mankind
gone I've said it before they're not as
they seem and with the anomalies in
their past I find them very difficult to
trust thank you guys for watching make
sure you like and subscribe for more
ideas of Ice and Fire